it's a bullying keV comm exclusive how
did you feel I know that the album came
out man and it didn't like you know set
the charts on fire per se like however I
really expected it to do more personally
I mean what's your take on that I mean I
didn't think it was I thought wow boy of
course I mean that songs was old by the
time though yeah I mean that wasn't good
one a message that's not about that one
on the house specifically because we
were like you know what analysis let's
just put on there though it'll go
platinum I mean the song mr. Dean was a
dope radio record I mean I felt like
that wouldnt work either original it's
weird though could honestly my life like
the Almaty good I feel I could be good I
forget if I get really good when you're
talking about no radio play you know I
mean that's real you don't say so we're
talking like I mean to come out selling
you know to be a triple to be in six
digits 6 ager sales with with no radio
play I mean do we know the charts and
see people with number ones that have
had you know 15,000 sales is like you
happens all I surpassed that you know
I'm saying like yeah that's a floor I'm
happy with that I mean like man that's
so you got that built-in fan base to to
where like no matter what you do you go
down know that you're gonna yeah they're
just gonna go up you know so the second
or mind or hundred percent I have
160,000 sales you know I'm saying so
it's like I can't do anything we really
go up and it's the second album even on
the horizon for you or use it in your
isn't in your head yet are you working
on it to be writing for it or not yet
I've heard you talk man like a drink lab
years of being with him yeah I mean we
actually just we always just pay homage
just every time I go to I know I saw
what did you just do to pay homage and
then you did you free salad for we
before that's right which is where
eight-mile was shot yeah and we just I
heard he saw how he wasn't still deal
with Obie Trice and he saw I may have
did that may have a false rumor Hardy
Saturday night right they get to the guy
there was two people playing guitar one
was my merch guy
okay steps we were doing a little cover
and he I mean all he does is play Eminem
you know so like but I came in the bus
and I was like yo I think Eminem heard
the song like I think I think you saw
the video excuse me
like
he was like dude look I saw me okay how
do you know like how do you know another
well he's like well yeah like you just
start freaking out you know the little
bit of happiness from that from another
person is crazy you know I'm saying
you've always been too dude to have like
some super over-the-top fans man yes yes
always whether it be chicks don't
panties into tattoos I mean and since
the last time I talked to you on this
new toys have been any new fan or
something new that you've seen it's kind
of like don't you back a little bit more
like okay I'm a hotel room and I thought
this is so disrespectful to like their
life you know just to me then it's like
dude you took it that far and it's kind
of crazy
yeah and it's kind of spooky but you
know it's weird though then it's it's
it's it's it's weird cuz I mean like
it's also super cool to think to like
the things people were doing to see
Michael Jackson and things are doing so
see us sometime saying like I may not be
the biggest but I think influential rise
like with whoever my crowd is man
whatever demographic you would consider
them like they do crazy stuff like just
to be around the music and be driving 22
hours that's crazy
this sweet man is so cool like
cross-country track they're like the
only thing I hope it gets frustrating me
is just like it's like the hotel it's
like it's like when it's clearly like
private I'm like let me just have that
cuz I'm not always gonna be on can't the
light be machine gun down there so I'm
not always gonna be like oh yeah this is
sick off some time gonna be like time
you know sometimes I'm an angry Kid you
know training I don't want it's not fair
to the fans to see to see that side but
exactly exactly but you can't ask for
that man if you're if you're if you're
camping out outside of someone's hotel
you are asking for that response like
this yes yeah but they don't understand
that like I try to do it yesterday I'm
just like dude like I mean I'm a
bathrobe man yeah you only stop like you
know something like what do you want
what do you know you do that's just so
awkward I'm having autographed my bath
house so weird dude but it's but I
wouldn't trade it for the world cuz I
don't know the phaser what gets me into
these radio stations and for the
interviews because that's what you want
to talk about you
have any any other people's projects
you're hopping on any features that
you're gonna be yes seed you know coming
up in this steve aoki work okay nice to
be okay you got a joint coming me and
meet have been talking with james is
just three for the longest oh no what
you know saying like me and me that we
always just go back on telephone stuff
you know saying so i don't know if
that'll happen or not so just I think
all that stuff's coming this this summer
because we meet or we just tore we don't
record and that's just for like mental
right reasons and then we are off the
road all we do is look or are going for
like a month and just knock stuff
yeah okay I will see what people through
it last time we talked man you had
mentioned and I had brought this up to
as I really thought it kind of really
was dope to me to see your response you
got in Harlem at the brother lore dude
has there been something that's
happening transpired in the last six
months it's kind of in an equivalent to
that for you personally because that was
kind of major oh actually that the
closest thing to that would be part of
it to a mile vein that's because when we
I'm not even someone we're on the steps
and someone when we were actually inside
the building and though the shelter was
right is right below right the level
with a concert venues that and so when
we did the the final battle verse from a
mile it was so on the spot like no that
was planned it was like you know do you
have this in terminal okay cool yeah I
got it yeah run that and like I knew all
the words you know I'm saying like Wade
without that it would just so happened
about end of the thing I was like oh my
god like II know I got could you know
out of you yet
and I can just stop and it ended up
going and what I saw people saying was
like I'm not even the type of person to
take out a cell phone at a show and film
but I know this moment will never happen
again
yeah in row I need to see yeah I needed
that for so I so that was like that was
something that I feel as I go I mean
that wasn't a song and that's from a
movie it's a free cell phone movie but
you know saying so like I don't think
anyone's mind was even thinking about
that and then also like not anything
easy for you to perform like just a
random-ass MC yeah exactly and so it's
in the end they sang it wrong it was
just that was a crazy moment any look
the camera angle looked like the 8 Mile
Island
it was weird man it was really eerie
that's what I was like before that like
I wouldn't know what I think if I was
Eminem when I saw her like a cat with
some cloud coming out and really just
digging a verse on that a movie you
might like you know probably things I
did I'll be crazy man that's what's up
man well the new mixtape Black Flag was
dropping yeah whenever we feel like
whenever he feels like he can get it
online merch and all that is online the
tour is how far you into the tour no
this is our last week coming up we ended
Seattle on the 12th there it is man go
support the homie NDK yeah you out here
doing this thing I'm glad to see you uh
you're in a better place man your your
you know what I'm saying I'm more
positive you banged out Rachel star you
know young yes it was man shots
MGK man is now a 98.3 bootleg cat all
right cool if I could just get you to
record one quick things I mean I do I do
a feature